reisen schneller als das licht wir
kennen das aus science fiction filmen
wie star trek und so weiter eigentlich
haben wir ja alle in der schule gelernt
dass nicht schneller sein kann als
deutlich dennoch sind forschungs siemens
weltweit dabei flüge mit über licht
tempo genauer zu erforschen und
vielleicht bald sogar zur realität zu
machen
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle
spannenden facts dazu ist der warp
antrieb physikalisch gesehen realistisch
und wie weit ist die forschung zu diesem
thema herzlich willkommen bei pixum
science fiction
ja und wir bei whatsapp dabei sein
könnte das erfahrt am ende des videos
die klassische physik und noch konkreter
einsteins relativitätstheorie erlaubt
die idee eines antriebs mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit einfach nicht
so viel steht fest noch die regel nichts
ist schneller als lichtgeschwindigkeit
gilt für eine sache nicht nämlich für
die raumzeit selbst also die grund
matrix des universums sie gibt es diese
obergrenze nicht und das bedeutet ein
wolf antrieb wie in star trek könnte
vielleicht doch funktionieren denn das
universum dehnt sich mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit aus bleiben wir
also mal bei dem fiktiven beispiel eines
raumschiffes denn durch den warp antrieb
wird eine lokale verwerfung in der
raumzeit erzeugt konkret bedeutet das
dass die kosmische grund matrix vor dem
schiff gestaucht und hinter ihm jedoch
wieder gedehnt wird ein stern der also
zunächst hinter dem schiff lag ist dann
lichtjahre entfernten stern der dagegen
weit vor dem schiff liegt der ist
plötzlich in reichweite verantwortlich
dafür ist die kompression der raumzeit
mit dem raumschiff passiert dabei sehr
wenig es bleibt zu seiner lokalen
raumzeit matrix gesehen unbewegt und
schwimmt quasi auf der welle der
raumzeit mit das tolle daran die
passagiere bekommt keine probleme mit g
kräften und auch einsteins gesetze
bleiben unberührt stellt euch das mal
vor wir könnten schneller als das licht
sein
das wäre wohl eine der größten
entdeckungen überhaupt und nicht nur in
science fiction filmen sondern auch in
der realen forschungswelt gibt es
theoretische überlegungen zum walk
antrieb schon 1994 gab es dazu ein
modell in dem der warp antrieb ein
raumschiff zehnmal schneller als die
lichtgeschwindigkeit macht erdacht von
dem mexikaner miguel alcudia
doch dafür notwendig ist eine lokale
raumzeit verwerfung und das kostet eine
unmenge an energie unfassbar viel so
viel nämlich wie die masse des jupiters
gespeichert hat um das zu umgehen könnte
man den werbering allerdings in donath
vom entwerfen und ihn in schwingung
versetzen diese idee kam einige zeit
später von einem nasa physiker doch in
zukunft ein weiteres
denn man wusste nicht einmal wie man die
raumzeit konkret denen und stauchen
könnte in dem modell von 994 war von
einem raumschiff mit exotischer materie
die rede dass man mit negativer masse um
geben müsse denn die würde dann gegen
die gravitation angehen doch wie genau
soll sich so eine negative masse wie
soll die aussehen wie soll sie entstehen
fragen auf die es bisher keine antworten
gibt dazu kommt eine tolle reise stünde
uns dann nicht in aussicht denn in einem
wort angetriebenen raumschiff wäre man
komplett vom restlichen universum
abgeschnitten eine kommunikation mit dem
draußen die wäre unmöglich so weit die
theoretischen überlegungen aber es gibt
auch schon experimente zum warp antrieb
weltweit beispielsweise meinte vor
einigen jahren in seinem experiment den
realen wort effekt nachgewiesen zu haben
den oszillierenden warp ring stellte er
mit einem hochspannungs ring kondensator
nach mit einem laser interferometer
wollte er tatsächlich eine verformung
der raumzeit registriert haben und zwar
um 1 10 mio
derselbe forscher war es auch der vor
drei jahren den so genannten drive
getestet hatte
das steht für elektromagnetische und
heißt eben so viel wie
elektromagnetische antrieb quasi eine
art elektromagnetisches capito mobile
und auch hier weitwurf anzeichen
entdeckt haben konkret bastelte sein
team einen hohen metall kegel der einen
mikrowellenherd feld enthielt die
mikrowellen photonen kollidierten mit
dem metall warnt und erzeugung weise
folge einen winzigen schub und
verformten somit gleichzeitig auch
irgend ein wenig die raumzeit doch als
andere forschungsteams das experiment
wiederholten konnten seine
messergebnisse nicht bestätigt werden
zudem sprechen sie gegen alle bislang
bekannten regeln der physik und so fasst
die nasa die ganze sache relativ
nüchtern zusammen zitat science fiction
autoren haben sich viele arten von
interstellaren reisende vorgestellt aber
schneller als das licht zu reisen ist
derzeit einfach die magie näher der
bordwand ried wird für die absehbare
zukunft weiterhin ein traum bleiben
ja und falls es uns irgendwann doch
einmal gelingen sollte würde das die
ganze wissenschaft auffüllen und neue
theorien werden dringend notwendig denn
dann würde unser
komplett ist verständnis des universums
kopf stehen und vielleicht passiert dann
auch das was in star trek vorhergesagt
wurde in dem moment in dem wir den warp
antrieb erfinden nehmen außerirdische
kontakt zu uns auf es bleibt also
spannend wenn er als erstes neues zum
thema warp antrieb und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp und zur
begrüßung gibt es ein kleines goodie
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das abo mit der genau mit der
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken fast wie
wolf antrieb antrieb ohne treibstoff
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran